hey everybody Doug Walker here I finally
saw bumblebee I'm so sorry this took so
long came out around Christmas like when
Aquaman and Mary Poppins came out I
already don't see movies around
Christmas and and I wanted to see those
two first that's just like so I'm sorry
and then other movies came out yada yada
uh a lot of people been asking me to
review this because apparently this is
like the first good transformer movie to
come out since like the first one I mean
even a lot of people didn't like the
first one so a lot of people been asking
me to Doug has been getting really good
reviews or at the very least
percentage-wise good reviews I know
everyone's always like just because it
got like 90% Rotten Tomatoes doesn't
mean that's how much they liked it I
know I know but you know it's still
there's gonna be usually more people
that don't like something or on the
fence or whatever you know it's gonna
affect that so I know if a movie gets
like whatever a hundred percent that
could be a hundred people saying it's
okay but still I feel like on the okay
bar people are gonna drop on more people
are gonna drop off so that's what I mean
by that anywho this has finally come out
this is the first non Bay directed
transformer movie and like I said that
live you been asking me to do it and uh
it's okay it's just see it it's okay I
know a lot of people hate and when I say
that cuz it's like they don't want me to
love something or hate it and it's a
very very very okay movie pretty much
the set up if you've seen the trailer
and you know the set up where it's like
you know the bumblebee is lost that one
of the Transformers has lost its a
prequel it's in the 80s it comes across
this kid and they form a friendship and
they're gonna learn things from each
other while bad guys come and try to get
them both transformers and the army um
if you saw them you're like that looks
interesting you'll like this fine I saw
it and said oh it's every one of these
stories we've seen before and it is it
but it's done alright if you want to get
really technical there's a lot of things
that don't make sense about it which I
mean for transformers you gotta
expect its its robots that turn into
alien robots that turn into cars I mean
of course there's gonna be stuff that
doesn't make sense but in terms of
character there's some things that don't
really make sense to me I did that kind
of got away from me but the performances
are good the actions okay man once in a
while it got a laugh it's if you like
this story you'll like you're fine I'm
sick to death of this story if you're
gonna do it I want something really new
for example lilo and Stitch that story's
been done it's the exact same story you
know this story trying to hide something
from another world to eat the et story
you're trying to hide some from another
world while other people are trying to
get you it's usually a kid usually the
two are gonna help each other out in
some way you know it's not actually
about the aliens it's about a connection
to a parent or a lost parent or
something like that and that's that's
this a bolillo and Stitch added sir
these new elements to it particularly
with lilo herself she's a great
character I mean there's no kid that is
that weird and that distinct and that
unique I mean it's just a wonderful
character and the connection with the
sisters is great so that for me may that
really unique this is every one of these
stories you've heard and there's really
nothing new but it's not done bad um
honestly when does movie started the
best part is the first three minutes I
actually like fan boyd hard cuz they you
get to see us with Cybertron is that the
name of the planet I think where the
Transformers come from and they are just
it takes place in the 80s so it only
fits that the Transformers Cybertron
everything looks exactly like the 80s
cartoon there's like so many of the
Transformers you grew up with like in
the first three minutes and they look
just like them they're not all Michael
Bay dies I mean they look just like the
original transformers and I just
uh and then you know one of them lands
to earth bumblebee obviously and he's
being chased down and and there's a cool
little fight it's in the mountains you
know just someplace that's not a city or
a desert thank you uh and it's a cool
fight and you're introduced to John
cno's this military dude who's you know
fun character actually he's he's kind of
my second favorite thing in the movie
honestly cuz he he has some good lines I
think our improvised but I could be
wrong but but he's very entertaining and
from there like his voice gets messed up
you know very Planet of the Apes you
know my like you can't talk any and he
falls and he has to go into hiding and I
was liking it so much that I actually
kind of got pissed off when I was
reminded oh yeah there's like as a kid
in this is like a coming-of-age story
which is so rare I usually that's what
I'm waiting for I'm waiting for like the
family connection the human connection
but because they start off on such a
strong nostalgic throwback that was just
so much fun it was just one of those
things so it's just like oh yeah it's
it's this movie um but for a good ten
minutes you get like a solid nostalgic
transformer movie which was really cool
and I I liked the first transformer
movie that Michael Bay won it's stupid
but I really enjoy it I felt again even
though that's a story that's been done
over and over these thing coming from a
newer world
again kind of befriending a kid and then
just turn into a big US versus them good
guys versus bad guys action we've seen
that before but I thought like the
action and the effects and the
creativity to the fights and everything
and the comedy we're all a lot of fun I
get stupid super stupid but a lot of fun
um we're with this one this one's a
little weird because like I I think it's
still pg-13 be shocked if it wasn't and
if they're making it look like it's a
little bit more like a lilo and Stitch
story et it's gonna be more kid-friendly
and there are elements of that but it's
still a pg-13 movie
like a lotta Transformers died a lotta
people died the way the transformers
gonna kill these people is both not
bloody at all and yet somehow really
disturbing and gory like there's their
shot and then they just burst into water
and it's like that's somehow like it's
not bloody but it's kind of creepy and I
kind of really dug it there's a great
line - he's like I like the way they pop
that's great you know seems like that
are great uh but then you kind of go to
scenes that are more kid-friendly like
bumblebee trying to get in the house and
he touches something and it explodes and
he falls backwards a destroys the couch
and that's more for little kids which
sometimes that can be combined very well
me as Aki does that law where he'll
combine like you know I love adult
elements a lot of kid elements and they
go together very well but something
Miyazaki usually doesn't try to do he
doesn't try to hit that thirteen year
old demographic and this movie still
very much does and the problem with that
if you want do that that's fine it's
what the first Transformers did I if you
do it well I don't care the problem with
this is that when you're trying to hit
that demographic you're getting this
action-packed you know super violent us
versus them you know there's some adult
jokes here and there and stuff like that
and then you just get this stuff that's
clearly meant for little kids a
thirteen-year-old I mean it's specially
at that age it's not gonna want to see
something that seems specifically for
little kids they want to ride that
adrenaline they want to ride that right
they want to write the inappropriate
jokes and everything so so those weirdly
felt out of place I can't felt that was
an issue with the toe and like you had
these two very I mean that's super
different but just different enough
where they didn't mesh all the time so
and then it's kind of strange too
because you hear bumblebee talk in the
beginning which I guess makes sense I'm
cyber trying to go he did have his voice
and everything but I mean he he just
seems like an average dude but the way
they kind of treat him in this movie I
think because other movies did this uh
is that he's almost childlike he's very
nice what does this do
oh well I don't understand they well I
guess I'll go really
over the top with this and it it doesn't
really make sense to the bumblebee that
they set up before you know he doesn't
act like the you know the shooting
warrior that that there was there before
where something like Iron Giant can get
away with that better because his mind
is totally erased it doesn't remember
anything uh though maybe even that was
going on they didn't kind of make it
clear cuz he can't talk uh whether or
not his memory has gone or not there was
something later it says like memory
rebooting or whatever so it's like oh I
guess he didn't remember I don't know um
so and then even then like how'd he get
his memory back I'm not sure so I'm
still not sure if they were writing that
or not but even if so I feel like he
still know is like his military stuff he
still knows how to shoot but I mean like
there's a scene where she's like again
you open up with bumblebee is shooting
these Decepticons everywhere and jumping
around and helping Optimus Prime and
then the girl is trying to teach him now
when you want to hide what do you do he
transforms into Akari it's like okay
let's write look there's a person she
goes behind a big rock and she looks
he's hiding behind a little rock now why
would a friggin transformer
why would this military-trained mind you
know that's obviously knows had to do it
because he's firing guns and stuff like
that hide behind a little rock I mean
that makes no sense
what made more sense was like in the
first transformer film you know he says
my parents are coming hide and they
turned into the cars but they're on the
front lawn that's something that would
match the characters they wouldn't get
it but that it doesn't match here
so there's scenes like that it's kind of
the same with the human characters to
where like the girl in this really wants
a car and of course she's going to get
the bumblebee car but she says to the
parents I really want car really want
car and the mother I forget her name
she's Bobby Hill she she's a really
great actress and she's good in this too
I mean everybody's good there's no bad
actors in this uh but she says well I at
the jump beat that's like five hundred
dollars we don't have five hundred
dollars yes you do this house is
huge it's like gigantic so that doesn't
make any sense but then later it's like
the girl's birthday it's her 18th
birthday like a big birthday and the
mother gets her a helmet and the kind of
stepfather the person she's dating gets
hurry how to smile more book and if you
like me you're thinking okay I know
where this is going cuz they're giving
like the corny smile and everything you
know and she looks annoyed she's gonna
go outside there's the car they got her
the car something nope they're just that
stupid and it's like no no they're not
the way these people are played they are
not that stupid they are not ignoring
their kid that much they are not this
ignorant you know they can be kind of
goofy and they can be forgetful but I
mean they are not that stupid and
there's kind of you have the generic
bully that like makes fun of the fact
that her father is dead which I mean
it's like you know it's a shame whenever
somebody needs to like just kind of
cheat on a character it'd be lazy with a
character it's always the bullies and
the more I think about the bullies could
be really fascinating characters you
know like the remake of it or the
cinematic version of it actually made
the bully kind of interesting and as
just like you know it kind of shows
where he came from and why he's that way
I mean it's brief but it's actually kind
of effective and it's like they're
always the ones that get skipped out
over and they're just a plot device you
know I mean there's one scene where she
comes up and she and she's like this car
is an embarrassment again what what kid
would talk like that but she said you
should really have your dad buy you
another one and it's like you could just
stop there because maybe she doesn't
know and that kind of opens up this you
know scar for her you know obviously but
then she goes oh wait that's right and
it's like no come on make him like a
real bully but you know I mean do come
on you're from Hollywood you're writers
you must have been bullied you gotta
know how bullies dogged and that just
seemed like so we're just doing this for
this cardboard cutout to come in and be
an N tagging is and then she gets her
comeuppance
um so so there's a lot of scenes like
that that don't make sense in terms of
characters plot I
kind of get it's not gonna add up you
know with the Transformers movie but the
some of those scenes with the characters
legit got to me and I was just like no I
really don't like that and then they do
some of the things like they're gonna
make you think like bumblebees dead and
spoilers he's not it's a prequel so of
course he's not um you know and even the
climax they're like you know it's this
whole thing about how they're gonna try
and bring more transformers to the earth
and it's like you you know you know they
might see you know that's not gonna
happen because it's a prequel so there's
not much suspense and the action is not
bad it's just kind of stuff we've seen
before you can actually see it a little
better that's nice um but with that said
I am II so those if you're looking for
like I don't know I guess you could say
nitpicky but they're not to me I mean
that's like essential character stuff
but if you're looking for stuff like
that to sort of be like we'll wait
that's taking me out of it a little bit
those moments are there but I feel like
anyone that's gonna see this movie
they're they're either gonna go in to
see like a die-hard action-packed
transformer movie which I feel like most
of the people going in are gonna know
that's not quite where you're gonna get
this is gonna be a little bit more
low-key a little bit more I guess
character driven even though their
characters you've seen before but but
but it is gonna be it's gonna take its
time or it's gonna be more depth and so
with that you might not get all the
action you want you might get some more
cutesy moments which I think could annoy
some people going in that want their
transform or their dumb stupid just
punch each other transformer movie uh so
so you got that audience I probably you
know it is interesting seeing and then
you have the audience that wants
something naturally is like very
emotional and and very you know does
something where you can make a
connection with this different life form
and and you can find out something about
yourself and everything and it's there
it's just very standard but like I said
if you're looking at the trailer of this
it really is truth in advertising I mean
that is the film it's that
straightforward story there's not really
much new but there's a lot of people
that
that story there's a reason it's done
over and over and over you know how to
train your dragon kind of did the same
thing I mean to me they added enough new
elements to it that make it kind of
different but it's like I usually hate
those stories but like you now train
your dragon I loved it so I think it is
and for a lot of people I mean people
that you like you know sort of morbid
character in their in their dumb movies
instead this is a dumb movie come on but
if that one more character more depth
it's here it is here and they act it
very well if the actors like I said are
all are doing a great job but if you're
looking for something new to kind of be
added to this formula this very obvious
straightforward for me like you're not
gonna get much so that is an issue with
me that it's a transformer movie that
for everyone saying oh it's really
different it's kind of the same just
from different movies you know I didn't
see too much new added to it but but
it's not but it's an OK version of the
formula the with John Cena I was saying
before I think some his lines are
improvised anytime there's something in
the story where you're kind of going
come on he kind of calls it out like my
favorite scene is when the Decepticons
come I use two Decepticons and you know
they're looking for bumblebee and
they're they're playing it smart they're
like you know we have the Decepticons we
are looking for this escaped warrior you
know if you do not help us find him
we'll bring war to your planet and all
you'd be destroyed and we don't want
that you know doing the obvious thing
Johnson of course the good military
American you know it doesn't trust them
and at some point he's bringing up his
concerns like a good soldier and when
he's ordered to do it he still does it
you know but at some point he just says
they're called Decepticons does that
raise no red flags for you it's like I
just be like that must have been
improvised or the other one is that
they're talking to the parents he's
talking to the parents saying that you
know you're your daughter's and
brainwashed by this thing you know she's
been through a traumatic event and
everything of course the parents don't
believe the kid because again it's that
point in the story where we had to file
this formula but there's a great line
where the
fathers just it comes from an unfunny
line where the father is saying
something like yeah I used to do a lot
of risque things it's like I stole I
don't remember what was you know I stole
a box of candy when I was younger and
liked it like that
similar to like what she did now that's
not funny but then John Cena says yeah
we know that's funny because suddenly
it's like oh he said this before like
he's that pathetic and it's like why
would you bring it up anyway and so that
subtly makes the scene funny and I
really feel like there's a lot of lines
in there he I feel like he was probably
written to be more straightforward like
you're tough military guys he added this
comedy I could be wrong maybe he was
always written like that
but the fact that he delivers it like it
sounds like he's improvising them I
think is really good and like I said the
big thing to praise in this is probably
the performances cuz they're not they're
not given much that you haven't seen in
a million other movies and they do a
good job with it uh the girl does a
really great job you really believe she
misses her dad
the stepdad is okay you know again he's
supposed to be kind of the all friendly
kind of dweeb guy step up but he shows
he can really help out I mean he's he's
not a bad guy which I'm happy to say I'm
glad there's no real bad guys apart from
the actually the Decepticons like they
should be the bad guys like they're like
that makes sense but the military aren't
really the bad guys or anything if there
is something where they where somebody
misunderstands something or it's just
being a jerk for a moment it's not for
very long you know they get to the
reasons you're seeing this movie pretty
quick so that's really nice and like I
said that's what I mean when I say it's
good it's a decent telling of this
formula but it does stick very close to
the formula and I would've liked a
little bit more variation one thing I
was really shocked about I guess isn't
really a spoiler cuz it doesn't happen
in it so this is a prequel and you know
bumblebee lands on the planet
Decepticons and two other Decepticons
and they're kind of building up how some
of the other transformers get there for
further coming movies of the following
movies and which is kind of
clever where was Megatron they the
military captures Megatron
they have him for like years and years
in the Army has him they have him frozen
everything like why couldn't he come
down why couldn't we see how the
military got him or whatever you not
like that could have been a lot of fun
you would have had the big villain there
but buddy's he's not in there unless
there was something in that first movie
that said that he was there beforehand
or something I don't know that what
makes sense so I don't know um it's it
kinda seemed like a missed opportunity
to be but maybe I'm missing some a there
was something in there that said
actually he came at a different time for
something so I'm not sure uh but yeah
this this is a perfectly serviceable
movie I objectively it's like the best
one because there is like the most depth
and character to it but but it's all
depth and character I've seen before I
personally like the first one a little
more because there was actual kind of
new stuff I haven't seen with the action
and with some of the comedy and it's one
of those things where I just sort of I
could watch that a couple more times I
think it's a lot of fun where with this
one it's like okay I saw the exact film
I thought I was gonna see with nothing
that much new added and it did a fine
you know I'm good I it's not really a
movie I watch to really feel you know
too much emotion or cry or anything like
that because again I kind of know the
formula where with the other one I know
the formula but at least it's good
action and it's funny and it gets my
adrenaline up so um it's so for me
personally I still like the first one
the most and then this one second and
the rest are just a rehash of the first
one again except they lose like all
charm and comedy and everything so I
yeah so that's my thoughts and I know
this film if I'm right I think I heard
it wasn't doing like great at the
box-office though frying it maybe it's a
slow climb I don't know and it's it's
not surprising to see why like I said I
mean it's like the people that want the
transformer fights are not gonna get
that much the ones that really want a
sentimental smart story are gonna get
hints of it but I don't think people
they're looking for that
usually looking for it in transformers
anyway and then the ones that really
want to go to a new place are gonna get
this very standard story so but it's not
bad it's you know very adequately done
that's really kind of the best I can say
about it but you never know you might go
see it you might have a real connection
you know with the characters and with
bumblebee and with the girl and
everything you might really really get
this strong connection to it so it's
worth checking out because maybe you'll
have a much bigger connection to it than
I did you know I thought it was alright
um I'm glad I finally saw our
transformer I'm glad I saw a transformer
movie that I can say oh that was decent
because given the last one three or four
I mean decent is a step-up I mean
they're being so predictable I think you
probably saw I did a video where I
predicted what was gonna happen the
previous one and and I still haven't
seen it but everyone's like yeah that
was pretty much I know like I was off by
one or two little tidbits but yeah I
mean and the stuff I was off I guess
like the little girl in that movie like
did nothing and I thought she would have
a bigger role it's like so the stuff
that's off about just made it worse so
it's nice to see something we're even
with this one I could predict it it it
would it still was done well enough it
had enough heart to in a hand of charm a
hand of good performances uh you know
it's one last thing I forgot to mention
uh the effects of this are pretty damn
good where and I I figured out why in
the other movies even though I like the
first one you know and and it looks cool
but doesn't necessarily look realistic
and everything if it might be the filter
that super high contrast filter that
Michael Bay puts on his movies where it
already looks a little kind of weird and
off when he does it so now you're gonna
put these robots in there as well that
aren't gonna blend in and now we have
this movie where they're it's played
mostly straightforward like the lighting
is even and it looks nice and everything
and there's scenes particularly when she
hugs
bumblebee like hugs the face or whatever
I mean it looks like she's he's really
there and she's really touching him and
hugging him
to a point where I legitimately can't
tell that did they build a bumblebee for
them then maybe see Gia's face a little
bit or was that all CG like I don't know
so that's something I like really have
not seen that transformer movie in a
while I liked in the first film there
was that novelty of never having seen
something that big and that grand you
know from these cartoon characters made
of metal just coming down and fighting
and throwing each other building since
tele we never saw that before and it
still shot kind of cool like it leaves
you to experience the awe and wonder of
it and then again the others just over
abuse it they just go too too far within
you notice the effects more and more and
they don't look real where this one
maybe because it took its time and then
the lighting was more even than they
just shot it like a regular movie uh it
looks more realistic or maybe see
effects Department I don't know but
whatever they did they did something
that really made it look like he was
there you know at least like 30 percent
of the time you know when he's walking
around you know it's CG and it looks
good you know but it's like okay well
that's not there but there's times where
it really looks like he's there and
that's really impressive
so um yeah that's about it
let me know what you guys thought guy a
lot of people been asking me to review
it and talk about it and I'm assuming a
lot of people really really liked it I
I'm wondering if going in maybe I'd
brought that hype with me and me that's
why so many people like because they
were just expecting another shitty
transformer movie you know so their
their expectations were low we did
suddenly raised where mine were kind of
high and then kind of lowered a little
bit when I saw a standard it was but but
I don't know and I'm wondering if other
people had the same reaction of this is
like their generation ZT I don't know so
yeah let me know what you think I'm
curious what uh what people really
thought of this movie um that's about it
check it out I do say check it out
because you might you know maybe you
won't get an emotional connection but
but if you do I feel like I feel like
the people that get an emotional
connection to this will really get a
connection and it's kind of worth taking
whatever the two hours to see if it does
so that's about it I will see you next
time take care
you